estas imágenes granuladas de circuito
cerrado de televisión muestran el
momento en el que se declaró un incendio
en una refinería de petróleo rusa en la
madrugada del miércoles según un
gobernador local la refinería de afipsky
fue atacada por drones ucranianos es una
de las dos plantas que fueron objetivo
el miércoles junto a otra en ilski ambas
se encuentran en la región de krasnodar
a mil kilómetros al sur el pueblo de
sebequino parte de belgorot justo al
otro lado de la frontera ucraniana
también fue alcanzado el martes los
proyectiles causaron daños en los
edificios así como heridas a los
residentes
Hola queridos amigos esta mañana no es
buena para nosotros por la noche o más
bien a las 3:15 de la mañana se llevó a
cabo un ataque masivo con misiles en
sheph benico mucha destrucción edificios
y departamentos casas particulares
muchos vehículos quemados cuatro
personas resultaron heridas están
recibiendo asistencia médica gracias a
dios Nadie murió
los trabajos de restauración comenzarán
hoy
en respuesta Rusia ha dicho que evacuará
cientos de niños de los pueblos de la
región el kremlin califica la situación
de preocupante
estamos preocupados por esta situación
el bombardeo de instalaciones civiles
continúa allí Por cierto no hemos oído
ni una palabra de condena de Ninguno de
los países de occidente en colectivo la
situación allí es bastante alarmante se
están tomando medidas
al otro lado de la frontera en Luján
también hubo ataques contra la pequeña
aldea de carpati que está ocupada por
Rusia funcionarios instalados en Moscú
dijeron que un puñado de residentes
murieron en la ofensiva los últimos
ataques se producen menos de 24 horas
después de que tres drones alcanzarán un
edificio Residencial en Moscú causando
solo daños leves pero provocando
evacuaciones ataques que el presidente
Vladimir Putin calificó de provocación